[Music]
preparing rice in an electric cooker is
easier than cooking rice on the stove
you throw in the rice and water press a
button and walk away until it's ready
this machine is designed to steam rice
to perfection rice cookers use indirect
heat to circulate steam around rice and
water from the outer pot to an inner pot
this process cooks the rice evenly in
half an hour
to cast the outer cooking pot aluminum
ingots are melted in a furnace a robotic
arm scoops up the required amount of
molten aluminum with a ladle then pours
it into the top of the mold it takes the
metal four minutes to cool and solidify
then technicians extract the pot from
the mold
[Music]
to refine its form the pot is mounted on
a computer-guided lathe as it spins
several machines contour the pots
outside surface to its final shape
[Music]
next the pot is loaded onto an automated
drilling machine the machine punctures
18 holes through the bottom
the rice cookers heating components and
it's painted steel shell are attached to
the outer pot through these holes then
the pot is returned to the computer
guided lathe a tool polishes the
interior until the aluminum is smooth
and bright a disc of stainless steel is
placed in a press the press molds the
steel into the inner cooking pot the
next press trims off any excess metal
around the top leaving a clean and even
edge another machine curls that edge to
form a rounded lip the lip strengthens
the pot and provides a place to grip
when the inner pot is placed into the
outer pot once polished the pot is
placed in another press this press
stamps water level lines on the side and
a trench on the bottom the trench helps
the water evaporate quickly next an
automated booth paints the rice cooker'
steel shells the shells are baked in an
oven for 15 minutes at 390 degrees
Fahrenheit so that the paint can set
with the pad printer the company logo is
applied to the shell technicians install
part of the switch mechanism to the
shell
another technician places the heating
element in a slot on the bottom of the
outer pot securing it with three clips
they install two connection plates used
to attach the steel shell a porcelain
plate and a magnetic core the core
controls the on/off switch based on the
temperature inside the cooker the
technician connects to power cord and
attaches the thermal insulation sheet
which allows the cooked rice to maintain
a temperature of 158 degrees Fahrenheit
this part of the switch mechanism hovers
over the magnetic core when the cooking
temperature hits 158 degrees Fahrenheit
the core activates the switch to turn
off the heating element and start up the
thermal insulation sheet after more
switch wiring technicians install the
fuse which prevents the cooker from
overheating one end is connected to the
heating element the other end to the
power cord by the porcelain plate the
painted steel shell is attached to the
base of the outer pot once attached each
connection plate is secured with screws
then handles are installed finally every
rice cooker undergoes a temperature test
after starting the machine the cooking
temperature is measured with the
thermometer once approved the cooker is
packaged with a cover and perforated
insert for steaming other foods to use
the cooker you put rice and water in the
inner pot and water in the outer pot and
under an hour
the heating element turns off and the
insulation sheet kicks in to keep your
rice warm